now let's start with performance metrics
for a classification problem
in this lesson we focus on describing
metrics for evaluating binary
classification problems
for example predicting whether patients
would develop heart failure or not
these metrics can be generalized to the
setting with multiple classes as well
but in this lesson we'll focus on the
binary setting
there are many evaluation metrics for
classification model
next we'll illustrate how they're all
connected
to depending on the prediction and the
ground truth value
we have four different possible outcomes
true positive
false positive false negative and true
negative
next we explain their definition in
relationship to each other
so the output of a binary predictive
model can be either positive or negative
here you can see a zoom inversion of
this
to differentiate with the ground truth
value we call this prediction outcome
positive
and prediction outcome negative
similarly we have the ground truth value
can be either positive
and negative again to differentiate with
the prediction value
we call this condition positive and
condition negative
if the prediction outcome is positive
and the ground truth's value is also
positive
then we call this true positive however
if the prediction outcome is positive
but the ground truth condition
is negative then we call this false
positive or type i
error conversely if the prediction
outcome is negative
and the ground truth condition is
positive we call this false negative or
type 2 error
finally a true negative occur when
prediction outcome and ground truth
condition
are both negative in fact this 2x2
matrix is called a confusion matrix
or a contingency table now we understand
all the definitions of this basic matrix
let's look at the relationship among
this matrix
first each row and column of this matrix
sum up to the marginal
for example true positive plus false
positive equals prediction outcome
positive and the true positive plus the
false negative
equals the condition positive and the
total population equals the prediction
outcome positive plus prediction outcome
negative
or condition positive plus condition